hey what's up guys there has been so
many of you that ask me hey Daniel how
can I stop my hair loss so if you're one
of the guys that are worrying about
losing your hair you're not alone
because estimates shows that two out of
every three guys out there in the world
start to lose their hair at their
mid-thirties so in this video I'm gonna
give you 9 tips to stop your hair fall
in their tracks and we're starting right
now
hey guys welcome to D LM model lifestyle
and this channel will talk about
everything that's got to do with
grooming style fitness and life itself
now this is your first time here please
subscribe and click the notification
bell so you won't miss the next video
now let's start with the first step to
prevent hair loss alright number one is
Minox Adele I mean oxydol is famous
across the world for helping men to grow
their hair now please know it will not
necessarily bring back all the hair that
you've lost but it will definitely help
you to keep the hair that you still have
left and hey just say no I'll add the
links of all the products that I'm gonna
mention in this video down here in the
video description below just so it's a
bit easier for you to go and check it
out so check out my knox Adele it even
helps men with those beards that are
kind of patchy it helps them to look
fuller now let's move on to the next
step
to stop your hair loss you need to take
more vitamin D actually you might lose
even more hair if you don't get enough
vitamin D why vitamin D well vitamin D
is kind of cool because it helps your
hair to reset its growth phase so try to
get more vitamin D through direct
sunlight or supplements you can also get
a little bit more vitamin D by eating
certain foods like cheese and egg yolk
and so on now apart from vitamin D try
to get some biotin and also fish oil
they will really help your hair to grow
thicker and faster as well now let's
move on to the next tip alright try to
get more exercise in general more
exercise can help you a lot with having
more healthy hair why because it helps
with your blood flow to your scalp and
your hair follicles which makes it a lot
easier for your hair to grow just don't
go crazy at the gym because you can get
temporary hair loss due to excessive
exercise this happens a lot to athletes
especially if they have poor nutrition
and bad hair care stop stressing so much
if you stress too much you can speed up
your hair fall a lot because stress put
your hair follicles in a kind of resting
state so they don't really grow as they
should anymore so try to tackle the
things that gives you stressed head on
and find solutions for them because just
ignoring the problems that gives you
stress is not gonna make them go away
well it depends on what it is right but
if you cannot change whatever gives you
the stress then maybe it's time to
change how you think about it and if you
can't do it alone talk to a friend that
you can trust or go and see a
psychologist
try to get ketoconazole shampoo now
that's not the name of the ship ooh it
is what is in the shampoo so try to buy
shampoo that has 1% ketoconazole in it a
good example of satin shampoo is Nizoral
now it's mostly marketed as a anti
dandruff ingredient but there's very
good evidence from research that it is a
very good entire androgen and it
basically blocks the conversion of the
testerone to hydro the testerone which
is basically a hormone that shrinks your
hair follicles and that causes your hair
to struggle to grow now when you get the
shampoo a pro tip is when you massage
the shampoo into your scalp just leave
it there for 2 or 3 minutes before you
rinse it now apart from the Nizoral
shampoo I'll add a few other options in
the video description down below so you
can check it out now let's go to the
next tip alright you can also try
finasteride what is finasteride well
it's basically a tablet or a kind of
pill that you take daily now just say no
you won't see any big changes right away
but just give it around 2 to 3 4 months
and you'll see some changes now you
won't get all your hair back but you
will get some back and it will also stop
your hair from falling you need a good
balanced and a healthy diet you need to
give your hair what it means to be able
to grow healthy and not fall off so I'm
going to give you a few examples extra
protein spinach and other leafy greens
for iron citrus foods for vitamin C and
nuts and seeds for omega 3 fatty acids
and then a whole grains for natural
biotin and carrots for vitamin A and
then also avocados for vitamin E
all right you can also try a laser
devices
now besides finasteride and minoxidil
laser devices are actually the only
other hair loss treatment approved by
the FDA that means a lot now how does it
work well basically the lasers are sold
as helmets or wants and they use low
levels of light but to be really honest
to you guys I'm not a hundred percent
sure that they work maybe they do I
don't know check them out in the video
description and your own research
all right you can also try a hair
transplant but a hair transplant is more
like a really last resort kind of thing
but if you feel like nothing is working
and you don't really want to go for the
bald look well just say you know I think
the bald look is cool just look at the
rock or jason stathom they rock it but
just now if you do a hair transplant
most people say that it is painful and
very expensive now I'm not gonna go into
detail about this but they basically
take some of the back here here and they
transplanted into the front but if you
really want to do it then you got a dear
own research about this now if you liked
the video give it a thumbs up and keep
your eyes out for my next video Cheers